all right so we are doing daredevil v
logs finally yes everyone's been telling
me to do this people keep asking me have
you were texting daredevil and I'm like
I've seen daredevil are you gonna make
doc watch daredevil I'm like I am gonna
make watch don't do daredevil are you
gonna make him do Felix I am gonna make
him do V loads and where we are dude
daredevil out that work again you had
such a good good thing going there then
hey you know what'll help
I have neat some local agency Pacific
case uh and we should point out right
now uh because there's only 13 episodes
of daredevil that after we are going to
do probably the most asked v-log series
I've gotten like yet Matilda the
animated series yes finally no we are
going to do Steven universe after this
as I thought you throw it out there so
you can stop fucking a scare is the
other question god you're Doug seen
Steven universe
uh I've ever seen someone seen you are
you gonna make Doug watch Steven
universe I will make this isn't I like
to see more than you Steven universe
though I am going to make you know I
mean that that's something I wanted cuz
I'll say I did see an episode or two and
I was like this I can do if you look
seriously this is actually very quite
tricky but key this is going on be his
recommendation yeah well pretty much
ready for a show is not fucking
everybody's recommendation to see the
show everyone I told you worst I know
it's true are you talking for everyone
else and so here we are finally gonna
talk about this show a huge hit on
Netflix everyone's going fucking nuts
for this decision to do it
episode by episode he's seen the entire
show I have not that we're just doing
episode one here um I mean shit should I
even compare that all to the movie um my
god what movie oh that was my first
thought when I saw the first episode was
I'm like oh well what daredevil movie
now like it just pisses all over that
daredevil I would say smug sense of
superior worry this for all the people
now it's a guideline
devil what's wrong with you I now can
you see what's wrong
I'm sure the drugs it's not is better
that's why everyone says as an example
of a good daredevil production healthy I
realizes the directors goes better and I
believe you I haven't seen a yeah but we
will talk about and we will talk about
cuz they're amazingly there are a couple
things in the Affleck daredevil movie
that I kind of like that I wish this
show picked up on a little more actually
so but overall the show sweep yeah well
unless talked about this episode this uh
you know I'd be lying if I said like
right from the beginning I was hooked I
wasn't but I think the stuff it does
that is Nellie different from the movie
of a very reminiscent kind of like of
early 90s especially eighties cinema uh
is that everything violence well not
just the violence uh the the origin
story right now with comic book movies
because there are so many of them has
kind of been done to death
uh and now it's funny that going back
now
uh to having somebody in a mask and
superhero outfit fighting crime who was
that guy then you'll find out the story
later is actually kind of new again
because we haven't seen it in what's so
old-school it's become new-school yeah I
totally agree so so you do get the
backstory that you know the he was a kid
and happened to weigh as a kid and he
sort of talks a little bit about dad
being a fighter but that's about it you
don't see too much gels and you know
there's more to it you know they don't
even really say about him like getting
his powers or anything you just know
they get it with us leaving with the
cheapness of his costume he's running
around like the Dread Pirate Roberts
yeah he looks like Todd in the shadows
kicking ass like it's so simple but uh
so you can get this going on and some of
it is is a little textbook like you know
the best friend or the partner I should
say also be the best friend who's just
really in my presence um and uh you know
and the build-up to this crime guy you
don't see yet and sort of the crime
business meetings and stopping the drug
rings and stuff um but there is this
there's a grittiness that doesn't quite
go too far it just me
the right amount of uncomfortable but
not in your face like we're trying to be
disturbing we're trying to be shocking
it's just the right amount of what's
needed and it creates an environment
where it's accepted that was what my
problems with the movie is that when
they would talk about like you know
another rape victim on the street you
sees a woman crying over this cartoon
gangster say yeah we met hit a little
fun and he has to listen to his fucking
harpy to figure out a guideline where
with this woman you know who the villain
would end up in he said yeah it makes
sense to listen to her heartbeat to see
if she's telling the truth and well
because she was found of her body
holding a butcher named with no one oh
but that's my meat that's a where makes
it well unlike the movie where it's
clear it's a fucking cleaner guys you
listening to that do you heart beat in
the movie like you could just tell like
the audience could tell it was just a
cartoony scene
yea orsa he's using it for legitimate
purposes so I mean I think people were
so giving me the wrong idea that it's
like you can't you know like we were
saying you can't be dark in a superhero
movie please do we would love it but it
has to be stuck up and this does step it
up well and the grittiness is something
that a lot of directors and production
designers and cinematographers don't
understand they don't know how to do it
right you know the best examples Man of
Steel where people are like it's gritty
oh it's so gritty it's not it's great
like there's a difference between just
desaturating your film and actually
making your film actually gritty this is
a thousand times more gritty and there's
tons of color all over this show
you know it's it you were telling me is
it my July's Sin City and watch I could
definitely see you're talking about
where the silhouettes and the shadows
are so strong but there is still color
shining through yeah shining down those
always it's black white and some
oversaturated color it is not a
colorless movie there's a ton of shadows
like half thanks Tim Burton's Batman
look like it was shot on the surface of
the Sun because I mean so much of this
show is just shot in the shadows
sometimes gotten the whip and a script
times like wait who is that guy couldn't
see who that guy was who is that you
know did he fight here this oh yes it's
better cuz seeing this episode again for
a second time now I'm like yeah it's a
little good the fights do get better
wait what wait till the end of it this
one open but that's a fine thing about
the fight is that and this was only way
there there there shot and the lighting
gets a little better yeah yeah I love
them a bit but the interesting thing
about the the fighting choreography is
that um you know they're doing stunts
and they're doing flips and stuff like
that but the actual hitting feels real
it feels like you know where you have
something like Fight Club where they're
not really like doing movie fighting it
looks like they're just hitting chair
kind of like how really guys in real
like what a teacher you know just you
know like that it's not stylized it's
not good-looking it's just it's all in a
lot of time yeah just okay wait so
you're gonna fistfight you have this
ugly this one oh but what I like about
it but then you have something kind of
even though I do I like the fighting in
daredevil it's way too polished it's
comic book and that's fine it was a
comic book movie um we're in this one
it's kind of like it makes it's very UFC
where it's like if they can do this job
they can do playset but they're really
fucking in each other it looks like they
will you join the fight they'll do it
and he does have martial arts experience
so he's doing that these other guys are
probably just you know learn street
fighting basically and it's it is funny
because you can see depending on who
he's going against I think there was
care taken in the fights to put him up
against different people sometimes it'll
be two martial artists together him
versus another martial artists other
times it's a street thug and the fights
change and kind of adapt depending on
him which is fun to watch well I'm the
guy he's fighting at the end of this one
you know he falls to the ground with
this guy's God and they fall to the
ground and they keep like if they keep
kicking and hitting while they're on the
ground there's kind of it that's
probably what I would do yeah yeah it's
not like you know and then do a flip to
get back up and and start but you know
it's not you would kind of like you just
when you're in a fight like you said
you'll fucking do anything to win it and
that's what you do you just you keep
going again anarchy okay keep going keep
going so I like it's a good mix of
nicely stylized but also kind of clumsy
in a sense where it looks like the
impact is real the sound is good
listen the cinematography is the same
like that's it's nicely stylized and
also looks kind of clumsy it's wet this
is what I wish uh lame Azarov
cinematography was more like cuz I'm
like it's handheld all over the place
but I'm like the shots are well composed
and makes sense there's not some random
Dutch angle just because hey I want to
show you half a ceiling like it's it's
still handheld and you know that sort of
intimate gritty sort of like almost like
documentarian cops kind of feel but
they're still good shots well you know
something I know you're talking about
the handheld and I think this is a good
example of not only how it can be done
well but how it can also make a scene
we're really nothing is going on there's
a scene with a woman's telling like her
whole story and backstory was on this
file and stuff like that her name is
Karen yeah that's a long like what 10
minutes of just these three that we're
looking at and no action is happening at
all and we're in the same room and
they're not moving it's pretty much just
her talking and they do it well cos a
they got a pretty good act pretty good
actors in this I mean they all do the
funny thing is that's not how I imagined
Karen from the comics necessarily but I
think she does a really good job so it's
one of those where I'm just like yeah I
like this a little different but they
pull it off and like the things where
they do switch things up I generally
think the show pulls it off really well
but on top of that I think we're always
that we say this over and over it's show
don't tell you know and there's a lot of
talk in the scene but there's a sense of
because it is so well handled you know
they're going to show as well and they
have been showing the murders and they
have been showing the grittiness so that
when somebody sits down is just talking
and you're holding on that shop for a
while you know like okay something
important is being said and I really
need to listen and they say it in a way
where you want to listen so it's a good
combination I feel yeah and it's not too
much of one thing it is funny because
like I've seen this episode so I showed
a couple friends as well so I've seen
this episode this is number three maybe
four so I've seen this episode the first
four episodes a bunch of times the only
thing that kind of like I'm looking back
I'm like okay what's critical I what is
there
weakness in this from a writing
perspective it's that confession scene
in the beginning each time like every
time I see it I get a little more bored
with it and I'm like yeah I'm not sure
and I it's not spoiling anything like
he'll go back and talk to that priest
again so I needed we know that's coming
anyway but I kind of always watch him
like I like the idea this scene just
goes on those dogging talking time you
know but I'm like it almost worried me
when I first saw this for the first time
that scene kind of almost ordered me
like this is gonna be really totally
good but this may just be really talking
and then like the show like completely
saved itself like right after no
actually but it's the only moment yeah
that I'm like huh see my point for me in
this episode you know that I have to be
honest when the partner came up sore
with his exposition ish dialogue like
it's not like painfully bad or anything
but it's the same thing where it's like
why when I sort of said this is foggy
soreness on you no no no it's not that
you know it's very no the righty doesn't
open that scene with the confession and
even even to some extent the kickin it
with the chemicals early and stuff like
that I was kinda say okay this isn't bad
bossy yeah by the book I thought that
scene was flawless just it could just
cuz it just felt it told you everything
he needed to know and there was an
intensity to it right away was it just
no no I got it yeah it wasn't just oh I
got hidden chemicals it was like no no I
thought was well done how do I say it's
that it's because I think it has been
done sort of so often even with their
done because I know the story too but
that's again I wouldn't know a way
around that this is probably the best
thing you can there's some tropes you
just need yeah you can't get around it
you know it's like they said I will go
with the test why I'm saying it's not
bad it's that well okay but no I agree I
thought that was a really good no
doggy's introduction like I actually
legitimately like the character you grow
- at least I did grow to really like him
um I like tomorrow when he was talking
seriously way is talking like a yeah
and he and like that intro was not his
best moment there's a couple moments in
the course of the series where I love
the actor I I I love the character but
there's a couple of weak moments over
the course of the series that was moment
number one there's a moment number two
well far from now right that is but
we'll get to that way like the fine
thing to watching this uh you know I got
through better call Saul this year that
they ran the season and I'm not allure I
don't like lawyer shows I don't get into
them but I like ones that do something
kind of different have a different angle
and better call Saul is one of them and
really I mean this one yeah it's a comic
book show but they they address the
legalese too you know they're not like
oh they're dumb kids they don't like you
the legal stuff or anything it's like
they're treating it as a dull because
there has been this big boom you know
with comic book movies and adult want
take it more seriously as well that
they're allowed to take this time at you
talk this stuff but talk in a way where
it's interesting it doesn't just be like
we're saying you know important-sounding
stuff where you go you know well that's
how that important so you know must be
you know we can follow it um and yeah
and I like how the you know Murdoch is I
do not read I haven't read daredevil I
really the most I know about is probably
the first movie I know very little about
daredevil I'm sorry I I mean yeah you
bro read they're done by me you know all
about it um so I didn't even know like
that woman was gonna be a main character
you know I thought maybe this was just
how shit sorry maybe I spoiled that for
no no no as soon as she says you know I
can help out I can help her ads like
well yeah I guess good vision yeah um
but yeah so it's one of those things
where I don't know the cure that much
going in but I think it's all the more
reason why you have to kind of create
that essence and likability very quickly
and I with the exception of the
confession scene which I think you're
right that's too much too early uh you
should say that um ISIL it was the sort
of pretentiousness that I'm like I
wouldn't have opened with that I like
you can get away with a scene like that
a little later give your own organ will
carry with it the hell down I was like
each time I see it I feel like
gets a little longer no your anyways
time I've seen it with friends you could
feel them squirming around a bit like
I'm like yeah you don't want that right
in the intro you open it with a guy who
has already been represented not very
well on a past movie that is infamously
like everybody makes fun of and hates
this movie and you opening with him you
know confessing his backstory pretty
much and crying and breaking down and
it's too much too early it really is and
so it's it doesn't destroy it because he
doesn't well I think we were going like
broke they're a little I think that was
part of it like make this dark and
gritty dramatic moment like not Ben
Affleck not Ben Affleck film like his
far removed yes that's what I thank him
figure uh but I like the fact that like
there is sort of this
yeah he's this guy he's fighting crime
and and stuff but I think the fact that
they start off that she's the first case
I think that's really brilliant like I
just thought you don't know how far
along has he been doing this for a while
or is he just starting out or how long
you been practicing now well what time
is it now five yeah that's seven out
that legit like I even had to ask him
like so cheese the first case like
really like that they're they're doing
this I just did not think they would
open well at the old and I love that
they did yeah but it also allows them
very much to show their first cuz nobody
supposed yeah well I think is their own
independent I don't know it might be
giving some away so I don't want a foggy
may have had a previous job with another
firm before I don't like I didn't do
them together yeah yeah we'll see so
maybe the two of them together I don't
know if that's the first time practicing
law well but bottom line it's not like
they've been doing the Lauria thing for
a while and then he got into crime five
yo there's only obviously there's star
guitar and I like they start that call
in that opening and I think there is
sort of this I the only way I can
describe a sort of like on what this
welcoming comfort to this guy you feel
like you're in good hands with this guy
like when he talks at it and maybe you
sincere he listens
yeah she said it he listens of course
he's blind what else is he gonna know no
but you know I like that's part of the
character is that's something that gave
something that the blonde
- gave him no you know sort of empathy
and ability to listen yeah I was gonna
say with um and I again I know it's
pointless compared to the F leg instead
but I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
comparison because I think this is just
good writing in general and this is just
the first thing I jumped to a Affleck in
the first film he didn't listen he
talked a lot he monologue online you
heard what he was thinking a lot and
with this one
like he didn't need to say that much but
what he said was short and to the point
and he said it confidently and I said
you know I I trust this guy that no
monologue but it's done in a print like
the confession he was monologuing but
that's what you should do you're in
confess I if you want to that was kind
of a weak but hey rule monologue but in
appropriate times like from what I
remember seeing it the first time we'll
see again as we watch it the second here
it seemed well balanced throughout like
Keith's got a silent part to him but he
also will if he doesn't say nothing I
mean he does talk about when he does
talk it's important and good stuff foggy
you get the feeling is the talker
yeah of the two of them he's the
schmoozer the you know whereas Murdock
is the silent type you know just
listening and collecting everything and
he doesn't say much but when he does say
it it's profound or to the point when
you know when she's really breaking down
and saying look I gotta go they're gonna
kill you and they don't kill you they're
gonna kill me and stuff like that and he
says you know she can stay with me I you
know I'll protect her I'll look after
her and I was waiting for her to say
something along the lines of you know
I'm much of a with him he you know he's
not blind but at the same time again
just the way he plays that she doesn't
know he's a crime fighter or anything
but the way he plays it you sort of go
yeah no I would trust that guy I don't
know I just trusted this guy you know he
is so confident and so relaxed and so
cover you ya know well this is the
difference foggy as a schmoozer but I
don't think he is quite the same level
of self-confidence where is I think
Murdock and the acting just exudes a
sense of you know D the look on his face
always says I know exactly what I'm
doing even if he doesn't yeah you know
which is a powerful thing because people
who just project that image of like I
know exactly what I'm doing
I know what I'm going to do and I'm
gonna do it now that's a potent thing
yeah uh thank God it's being used for
good um
we'll find out those who use it for bad
later I do think we should talk about
the villain so far because I am in love
with Wesley that guy is he that the
lawyer the the lawyer who walks in the
house kind of say is that that guy with
the glasses yeah oh but yes but I like I
just I love this character like the way
he walks in and does the whole thing
with the the iPad there and like hey
wave hello to your daughter give her a
call like that whole set up I'm like wow
that in a couple minutes there that told
us everything we need to know about this
enterprise they have people everywhere
they will go to any lengths to blackmail
somebody they want favors from people
high up you know with the cops and
they'll threaten the lives of your
children to do it and have the means to
do it well and I was saying I actually
do like a big normal say I like that
they follow through and they did kill
the cop you know and she brings the
laundry bag yeah I mean it's sad to say
but I love the payoff it's almost a joke
but it's like but it's I mean it's a
payoff to I do notice it's a payoff to a
seem like I would bring my laundry bag
this weekend a little I think he's dead
at the ya know it's one of those things
where it's rightfully disturbing yeah
you know you want these guys to look
like bad guys they did bad things so you
didn't need to wait you didn't need to
see the following or torturing joy they
just him you know hurt her reaction to
him being dead I mean that's enough yeah
me that then he did it and you know why
you saw the build up any of those
uncomfortable scene with them looking at
the daughter on the iPad everything if
it were a comedic scene it would be a
topper like it would be the perfect
punchline I mean it's not it's dark as
fuck but I mean it's just I kind of
respect this as being so well written
like I just love the payoff of her with
the laundry there and just you know I'll
say well one last thing here um about it
I think he kept telling you know me but
I liked it um is that I was talking
about sort of the
bringing back you know just the hero
exists and we don't entirely know the
full backstory and we're gonna get more
of it as we go on I mean we know you got
them with chemicals but even then didn't
really say you get superpowers from this
I mean we kind of know but um is that at
the end something I really miss and I
only see once in a while and I hope they
bring back because it was something that
died out it should have died out it
should stay around is the montage oh my
gosh I love what they do montages and
stuff it's such a shame they don't
adorable and yeah I just forgot it's
like man does I give me ready for the
next one excited for you know what's
going down and I'm thinking all the
times I've seen a minute a montage even
in a bad movie it's like it's always
their work when they do all my work
yeah so I'll please those going it you
know they're just so when they're edited
together they're done right there just
so wonder the Marvel comic universe
references were nice to Hell's Kitchen
being blown up by the a yeah I would
have noticed that you didn't bring that
um well they get more obvious with as it
goes I'm but I love the concept that
these villains are reaching off of
heroes Leland says at some point was
like what we love these guys they blow
up a building somewhere and we're trying
to put new ones up like I just I love
that idea
oh yeah no it's not something that I
don't think is explored enough the
concept of like well you know the heroes
need the villains you know to justify
their existence but this is a case where
the villains told me need the arrows to
cause the damage so that they can you
know do these racketeering schemes and
you know no that was a nice touch um I
love all I think for me I was hooked at
that scene where all the criminals meet
up cuz I just got this you know me too I
got this I got abyss sounds maybe I've
got this sense of synergy when all the
criminals were there and Wesley was
talking to them you have the Russian
mafia you have the Yakuza I am assuming
Gao represents the triad the guy head
Adams yeah we're gonna make doctor's
idea Lee Owen does the money like and
when they're all talking together I got
chills when I watch that scene the first
time and I'm like and you know that you
know they're all being run by somebody I
mean I think we can guess if you know
anything about daredevil but I won't
spoil it for you yet
okay I wonder who it is my kids its dr.
octopus oh um
Doc Ock is running them all it's cuz
he's got a good toys he's got so many
hands he's got his hands a little bit of
everything for another prize but you
know what it is I just yeah I just got
goose bumps and it will seen his handled
so well you know the show like I said
it's being done you know it kind of by
the numbers up until that point where
it's like now we're gonna give you
something a little different you ever
really seen these kind of crime algae
you see the Russian guys you know what
the doc sentence abut I mean you ever
really seen kind of these villains
before they haven't seen a lady gal yeah
I love this old Chinese woman running
this drug enterprise yeah and I love you
know the guy you know just going you
know why are we waiting here I love a
blonde the other guy coming in not with
the boss but he's very you know per se
he reminds me uh yeah cuza
the Yakuza gay uh uh no that again that
guy with the glasses uh Wesley he
reminds me member in gargoyles members
Antos uh helper what the hell's his name
the blonde Oh
his assistant yeah you're having a lot
of s what funny you should say that so
it did yeah that pretty much nails is
character but it's something we're
answer watching it us are like you know
yeah just now this is kind of different
I like this it kind of went off from
there and okay this is where we're gonna
be a little different and do things you
know that are gonna make it stand out
because before it was good it was kind
of a typical crime superhero whatever it
was done well but I can't see him before
and then it's sort of the not it was
sort of taking a few more chances and
doing things a little bit more quirky
and different yeah that is funny yeah
that is exactly the same scene where I'm
just like this is where I that scene I'm
like I'm hooked
I gotta see where this gone because I
just loved this meeting here like the
other characters kind of have to be set
up they you know you just got
immediately you know you got like their
character and they're interacting will I
say we're talking archetypes and they're
all based on their actions and
mannerisms but it really works it's like
I don't need to know anything about
these view I think I'm just gonna figure
it out look at that it's like you got a
bunch of eighties character actors
together room like all these guys enter
you bring Ella know their own video like
eighties character actors are all
that right amount of over the top where
you don't need to be told what their
motivation is you can just look at them
it's like I get it yeah
and I could just watch Leslie do his job
all there I just love him running in
fixing problems talking in the car and
you know
oh yeah well don't worry he just
overdosed on drugs like an hour now oh
he's leaving this trail of bot eats so
um ya know a good star definitely got
better as it went along as most first
episodes do I mean to be fair um and
yeah we're we're just gonna run through
these I can't say exactly whether
they'll come out we're just gonna do our
best I mean we will film a with them up
it's not going to be like this whole
week's gonna be done but they're devil
we're just gonna do our best and for
anyone wanting more adventure time V
logs I get kinda same thing we'll just
kind of do our best to fit in a wherever
we can but yeah Daredevils a hot thing
right now and everyone's in go see it go
see it and as you should yeah exactly so
and after that we'll start the Steven
universe is which I'm sure we're gonna
be plenty I'm sure yes but yeah right
now we got these 13 to go through so
just keep an eye out just keep coming
back whenever we post them and just keep
watching us Yap so see the next one